women want to be acknowledged and
recognized for their achievements yeah
so if you could pick one
would you rather be recognized and
acknowledged for your beauty or would
you rather be recognized and
acknowledged for your career
and your accomplishments that are work
related
well there's a short window right that
you have your beauty so
after four yeah I mean I'd like to look
back on something I mean I want to be 80
years old with my husband and be like
look what we created you know
yeah
okay so more so your accomplishments
than your beauty so talking talking
today rather than When You're 80. So
speaking today where we sit right now
are would you be more interested in him
acknowledging you for your beauty or
having him acknowledge you for your
accomplishments
yes pick one
um
I mean in a relationship I just want to
be loved for who I am
right but I mean if you
so like let's be honest I mean if we're
going to love us for Who We Are we
wouldn't eat healthy go to a gym dye our
hair put on makeup wear bras and you
know like all that stuff right like we
would just show up
Fair statement right so like we like we
apply things to sort of you know enhance
Beauty
um I mean guys have their own version of
it women have their own version of it so
I guess
again going back to the original
question I'm going to press you on this
is would you rather be acknowledged and
recognized for your beauty or would you
rather be acknowledged and recognized
for your accomplishments
and the same questions coming at YouTube
to Chelsea so think about this while
we're talking to Jenny
you know not everyone has a luxury of
having this incredible beauty you know
not all of us are you know the 10 out of
10 beautiful women
and I think that's why we're kind of
talking about these like body positivity
moves like not everyone is going to fit
this mold and so I definitely don't fit
that mold I'm not a perfect hem so I
would I don't really I'm not ever gonna
be the most beautiful girl in the room
and I want to have my accomplishments to
fall back on you know not all of us can
go and be runway models and celebrities
and you know Instagram models so
um yeah I think it would just be
unrealistic for me to say I Could Be
Loved for my beauty and my beauty
forever since it's a short window I'm
not as genetically gifted as someone who
maybe is a model
and I have intellect and I have these
other things I can offer so I can only
be myself you know so I have to be
appreciated for who I am never going to
be the perfect 10. and I try to
appreciate whoever I'm with for who he
is too and he can be unique in his own
way doesn't have to fit some mold of
whatever it is he thinks he needs
okay so yeah we've got the chat saying
that's a non-answer but I get what
you're saying so Chelsea at you now
would you rather be acknowledged and
respected valued for your beauty or for
your accomplishments
right now in Life or today yeah as we
said here
a hard one I don't feel like I have many
accomplishments right now as is
so it's hard to picture that
um
with that being said like the easy
simple answer just because I don't have
those accomplishments right now it would
be the beauty but if I were to get some
things on my hope to get done at that
point it would be
my accomplishments
so let me try a different angle really
quickly because I want to make sure so
you ladies agree that
maintaining a level of attractiveness is
relatively easy eating healthy working
out putting on some makeup not eating
like [__] you know going to the gym
every day and giving giving a [__] about
what you look like basically when you
say that's
relatively easy or would you find that
that it's relatively difficult
that's easy
so on the other side of that coin when
we talk about accomplishments in going
out and sort of putting a dent in the
universe and maybe it's writing a novel
or it's making a bunch of money or it's
getting a major promotion at work or
it's going and starting a business
would you say those things are harder
than maintaining beauty or they're
easier
all right
it's harder I've had your choice to if
you had your choice of the two
why not default to what's easier
especially
knowing that men are Beauty Seekers and
youth Seekers and attractiveness Seekers
and they're generally not as likely they
don't have a natural proclivity towards
your accomplishments or your wallets or
your mahogany framed diplomas let me
just let me just for a second
yeah let me just interject for a second
because I'm not sure that
that the gals understand the um
statement so
um
maybe I should just overtly say it like
do you think that men appreciate you for
your beauty
I'm under no delusions about what men
look for
um have you ever have you ever had a guy
you know over at your place and he's
looking like I'm assuming that you guys
went to college or university
you've got you know your accomplishments
your degrees Yeah
you too Chelsea yeah yeah like have you
ever had a guy like come over you know
you got all dressed up you put on your
makeup you got your hair your legs your
like everything's looking fine and he
comes over and he ignores you and he
looks at your degree on the wall and
says that's that's a nice degree I like
that that's
absolutely no delusion
youth Beauty fertility femininity
agreeableness you know maybe you have
any good personality sex
but we're talking about my red flags
right this is so what I'm getting at
then is if you're under no no delusion
that that's what men appreciate in women
then why why is it important that he
acknowledges your accomplishments
because that's what I'm looking for in a
partner I want someone who goes beyond
you know that kind of caveman mentality
and can see me for my intellect and my
my abilities and I'm just that's that's
what I'm looking for you know
got it got it the it's like it it starts
to generate a list of disqualifiers
though right like
um you know he's got to be over six foot
because you're tall so he's got to be
tall good looking highly masculine do
you know what percentage of the North
American population is actually over six
foot tall
take a guess
two percent no it's more than that two
two three percents over six foot three
but I mean like we're talking you know
like if we're talking six foot it's it's
it's in the teens right like there's not
a lot of guys that are over six foot
tall in North America and like let's be
honest like if you're 5 10 I've dated
five ten and I'm six two and in heels
you're the same height as me so it's
like like six foot probably isn't tall
enough like you need to be able to look
at least at the guy or slightly higher
Adam when you're in heels too like when
you go out right yeah All My Exes have
been six too yeah
so that that's a very very small part of
the population so you're talking less
than five percent of the population now
and they and they have to be successful
and they have to be highly masculine and
they have to be shared in interest and
be interested in a little bit of Woody
banter with literature and you know
support you and have family values and
be really good looking and confident and
not needy not a jerk and have to want to
praise you for the account like the list
starts to get long and I'm just
wondering if the disqualifiers are
going to be problematic for you over the
long term like what do you think about
that
like if you got all this stuff and he's
like you know what babe just write your
book
like what do you need for me you know
you need okay you gotta publish like you
need an editor like what can I do to
help help you out here
I think we are just discussing what my
red flags were and I'm under now
delusions about what men look for and I
know why
why to me yeah but I'm just explaining
what I'm looking for and why some of my
relationships haven't worked out because
I think there are things that are
missing and maybe I'm looking for
something that doesn't exist but yeah I
think that's it yeah yeah once you start
going to all the requirements and then
you start adding the disqualifiers
you're limiting yourself to a very very
very small part of the male population
and that's that's going to be
problematic like do you see the problem
therein
yeah I mean
I totally see it and
um maybe what I'm asking for is too much
it's possible do you have any other
standards that you've that you've found
were difficult for you know guys to meet
people just qualify them what's up the
ability to think selflessly about what I
may want even even if it's not what you
want as a man
and the kind of understanding me as a
woman and me as a unique person what I
desire in a relationship
and a lot of men can't think past
themselves
whereas I'm more than willing to think
past myself and to contribute to them
and to be whatever they need
and I kind of want that back so you've
just described solipsism
but you've called men solipsistic
like their own reality is their only
reality yeah like you can't see past
your own nose right and I think one of
the things that men uh find frustrating
when they're dealing with women is they
find women generally across the board
are fairly solipsistic right like they
just
you know what I said like one of the
things that I say that just blows up on
the Internet is women don't care about
your struggles they hang out at the
finish line and they pick the winner
and all that really means is
they don't have time for your [__] like
they want you to figure it out and if
you can't then they'll just pick
somebody else basically so there's so
many options like we have more options
than you can imagine and so if I have 10
people hitting me up a day
right but I mean are you interested in
all 10 of those options
no
what percentage of those options that
are one percent one one percent
sorry did you say one one percent so
only one percent of the guys that are
hitting on you or express interest in
you you reciprocate with the same level
of Interest the same level of genuine
desire
is that what you're saying
I meet someone maybe one of them I'm
interested in then we have to see where
it goes like we'd have to go on dates
we'd have to communicate we'd have to
talk on phone
oh yeah there's a long Litany of stuff
that has to happen you got to check out
his family you gotta he's got to check
out your family they got to see if they
get along do you guys have reasonable
what happens when you know when there's
chaos in your lives you know luggage
gets lost when you travel to go visit
for Thanksgiving there's lots of tests
along the way that happen right
absolutely yeah but
do you think at all like there's any
there's any disqualifiers there that are
existing that are potentially making it
difficult for you to find a husband so
that you can have a family in those
children
yeah I think that's exactly what I told
you I want someone who cares about my
passion
yeah it might be too much to ask I
really hope you guys enjoyed that clip
if you want to watch the full length
podcast you can find that over here that
clips from if you're new to the channel
make sure you hit subscribe over here
and pin down below in the top comment
you'll find a bunch of useful links to
my website my supplement line books and
a bunch of other stuff have an amazing
day peace out